das wovor alle immer gewarnt hatten ist
jetzt im kongo passiert und es erinnert
sehr an den dramatischen verlauf in
westafrika wo er mehr als 11.000
menschen starben wir hatten ja ja das
schreckenszenario von super verbreitern
beschreibung genau das scheint jetzt
geschehen zu sein die neuigkeiten aus
dem kongo jetzt per klick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
ebola ist ein fieber das in rund der
hälfte der fälle zum tod führt es
beginnt relativ harmlos wie eine grippe
aber im weiteren verlauf fangen die
opfer überall an zu bluten und sterben
schließlich an multiplem organversagen
übertragen
die krankheit meistens von sogenannten
reservoir würden das sind wildtiere die
gejagt und gegessen werden
durch die abholzung von wäldern rücken
menschen immer näher an diese
populationen heran und jagen dann
flughunde affen oder zum beispiel
stachelschweine dieses buschfleisch
führt dann meistens zum ausbruch der
seuche im kongo ist das jetzt geschehen
wir hatten ja darüber berichtet und wir
hatten auch noch mal beschrieben was sie
solche in westafrika so unkontrollierbar
gemacht hatte super verbreiter hatten
die solche an große personen gruppen
verteilt die sie dann weiterverbreitet
hatten ein anders war zum beispiel der
tod einer heilerin die dann von
hunderten menschen bei ihrer trauerfeier
rituell gewaschen wurde sie alle hatten
sich dann angesteckt und die solche
verbreitet und genau das scheint jetzt
auch im kongo passiert zu sein
doch die folgen könnten hier
dramatischer sein des ebola bereits und
das war damals nicht der fall
in einer millionenstadt in dem band aka
aufgetreten da kam es jetzt zu einer
dramatischen situation so klemm klammer
dollar 2 hat seine grenzen schilderte
die flucht von drei patienten aus einer
station im bann dakar zitat die
patienten befanden sich in der aktiven
phase der krankheit und erbrachen so der
arzt laut der washington post ihre
familien holten sie aus dem krankenhaus
legten sie auf motorräder und nahmen sie
zu einem religiösen treffen von 50
personen mit ebola ist durch
körperflüssigkeiten anstecken und beide
patienten die sich in einer akuten phase
der krankheit befanden starben innerhalb
weniger stunden danach damit ist der
worst case eingetreten sie und das waren
insgesamt drei sogar dürften dutzende
menschen angesteckt haben und dass eben
in einer millionenstadt zitat in allen
drei fällen wurde von den
krankenhausmitarbeitern alles
unternommen um die patienten und ihre
familien davon zu überzeugen ihre
behandlung nicht zu verlassen
was erklärt barrieren brust sagt eine
pressesprecherin von ärzte ohne grenzen
zitat es ist bedauerlich aber nicht
unerwartet
das sagte tarik jasarevic sprecher der
weltgesundheitsorganisation who
zitat es ist normal dass menschen wollen
dass die lieben zu den letzten
lebensmomente zu hause die ärzte märz
sehen so wie jetzt fieberhaft nach allen
kontaktpersonen um sie möglichst schnell
zu isolieren aber dieses ereignis könnte
ist jetzt deutlich erschwert haben die
solche zu kontrollieren
wir hatten ja schon geschildert das ist
außenbahn dakar erheblichen güter und
personenverkehr in die hauptstadt
kinshasa gibt und man da kam mit rund
1,2 millionen einwohnern bietet dabei
den idealen nährboden um eine solche
schnell zu verbreiten es gibt kaum
elektrizität und noch immer nur wenig
sauberes wasser die menschen die mobil
und können den erreger innerhalb von nur
wenigen stunden
anders als im ländlichen raum im ganzen
kongo verbreiten kommt die solche dann
in kinshasa an dann ist viel schneller
mit einer internationalen verbreitung zu
rechnen als es noch in westafrika der
fall war
im gegensatz zum ausbruch 2014 ist die
weltgesundheitsorganisation dieses mal
aber deutlich besser vorbereitet ein
experimenteller impfstoff wir hatten ja
die repariert berichtet ist dort bereits
im einsatz und es wurde bereits mit der
impfung von 628 kontaktpersonen also
pflegepersonal und ärzten und ärzte
begonnen
ich hatte euch versprochen euch auf dem
laufenden zu halten diese nachricht die
zum beispiel noch nicht in etablierten
medien zu finden
das mache ich auch weiterhin er wisse ja
dass das abo modell auf youtube nicht so
richtig funktioniert deshalb wenn er
also nicht zum ausbruch verpassen wollt
und als erste informiert werden wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer
bei whatsapp und den anderen messengern
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren der
vater als neuestes aus der social media
welt das aktuelle zum beispiel jetzt die
anhörung von mark zuckerberg vor dem
europäischen parlament aber nicht die
genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es
weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken neuer ebola
ausbruch die vorgeschichte des ausbruchs
definierter da ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran